from The Washington Post Pentagon
surging thousands of troops toward
Israel amid Gaza War the US is
projecting military strength in the
Middle East as its diplomats race to
prevent the crisis from erupting into a
broader conflict I'm just going to say
it seems like they're not succeeding in
that and actually I think the US
presence may actually make it worse
here's the reporting deployments
disclosed by the Pentagon in recent days
will surge thousands of US troops Tor
Israel I love how they keep saying Tor
projecting expansive military strength
in the region as American diplomats race
to prevent the war in Gaza from erupting
into a broader conflict the move include
the moves include the deployment of two
US aircraft carriers and their
Associated escort ships hauling some
15,000 Personnel combined the
repositioning of an amphibious task
force made made up of about 4,000
Marines and sailors and undisclosed
increases to fighter squadrons already
arrayed throughout the Middle East
another 2,000 support troops have been
put on alert and told they should be
ready to go within days the move follows
hamas's stunning crossb attack on
October 7th this we all know now I I
feel like the reporting we got on this
one was put in the cart before the horse
and I think it was intentional they're
saying it's not an aircraft carrier
Striker it's two so an an additional
deployment they keep saying in the media
they're being deployed towards Israel y
they're being sent to the Mediterranean
just outside of the conflict right and
they're saying the Pentagon is preparing
them to actually go on the ground I I I
I was worried about this last week when
they reported uh us hostages were taken
I said that's usually the United States
sending in ground troops Special Forces
or something to go in and make those res
that rescue Gaza is not Iran so it's
more likely something like this could
happen but we the reporting we got the
other day was that 2,000 troops were
being prepped to be deployed just
outside Israeli Waters now the
Washington Post is telling us actually
19,000 Personnel already there with
2,000 more being prepped to go and
potentially into the
country yeah uh it with the news that
they tried storming the Israeli Embassy
this is all happening right now there's
there's a bunch of conflicting reports
Hospital been being bombed uh uh the
meeting between Biden and Jordan's being
cancelled now it it seems like war is is
I think they're afraid they're afraid to
say War you know like everyone no one
wants to say I want to deescalate I
don't want war Netanyahu said war he
said war outright he declared war on
Saturday we also had Hezbollah which is
the Lebanese terrorist group they called
for a uh a an unec a day of anger
tomorrow um globally for jihadis
everywhere uh in response to Biden's
visit to Israel yeah they're saying
they're saying War they're saying War
well Hezbollah is saying war and you
also have Hezbollah and Hamas are are
backing each other even though one is
Shia and one is Sunni but they hate the
Jews in America more than they hate each
other mhm so the the big concern is uh
uh right now we have this reporting from
ABC News Biden has Departed Ed for
Israel and canell the the Jordan Summit
I believe I don't know exactly why let's
let's actually just uh just pull this up
and see what their the latest
development uh development is uh they
say Israel at least 400 people have died
3,400 have been injured Israeli forces
launched air strikes this we know
conditions are are getting worse and I'm
wondering if uh there's the hospital
strike it doesn't seem uh he's departing
for Israel but it's not explaining do we
know why the the Jordan uh uh uh meeting
was cancelled my concern is that there's
thousands these these videos thousands
of people I don't want to call them
protesters because it's it's it's it's
more serious than that they're not quite
rioting though but I wonder if this is
the reason why Joe Biden is saying we
can't we can't have this meeting or if
it's because the Jordanian government
was like that's it the the strike on
this hospital is too much for us we're
we're not having this we don't want the
liability of the US president here I I I
think it's the former and I one of the
things that's striking here to me is why
would you announce that's hug that
you're going to Israel as the President
of the United States they're in war
right now why would you do that where we
got two strike carrier groups moving in
we have escalation all around the
borders of Israel right now with Jordan
Lebanon and so on and so forth and now
you're going to announce as the
President of the United States that
you're going to go to Israel where
Hezbollah obviously has the capacity to
be able to reach Tel Aviv Jerusalem
so on so forth with any type of Hamas
Hamas and Hezbollah yeah Hamas and
Hezbollah you know it just seems like a
terrible situation CNBC is saying that
Jordan cancelled the summit because of
the bombing of a hospital in Gaza now
there's a video of this and and and I
don't want to just rush too far ahead
with all of this stuff that's coming out
now but there is video that appears to
show it may be a rocket misfire although
many on the left are arguing that it was
a failed Israeli inter ception in which
case there's a lot to talk about here
but before we get into all that let's
just say Joe Biden let's we'll stick it
we'll keep it to the Joe Biden subject
right now I'm seeing people tweet the
concern that Joe Biden could could is
risking his life for no reason these
conversations can be had over the phone
from secure locations and going to Tel
Aviv right now going into Israel stupid
yes it it does it doesn't make any sense
but it shows it makes sense if you want
to cast his belly to bring the us into a
war in the Middle East but it doesn't
make sense for reasons well and let's
say you know God forbid and I me among
any many people would not want something
like that to happen some type of
escalatory conflict in the Middle East
but gosh wouldn't that look kind of uh
opportune to maybe invade Taiwan if
you're China CH well that is the next
thing I mean the next the next thing
we're waiting for is for China to go you
know lay Siege to Taiwan that's really
just the final and you just move two
strike carrier groups over there so
that's basically fifth Fleet which is
stationed in Bahrain has now moved over
there and repositioned themselves off
the border of Israel third Fleet which
is out there in the Pacific on their own
wouldn't have any reinforcement because
fifth fleet's now tied up right what
would we do well we would have what then
we would have a war on three fronts yes
not to mention a pora Southern border
right yes with fears that Iranians have
already been captured Crossing through
as well as people on the terror watch
list so well and and they've reported
that that people on the terror watch
List have been captured at the southern
border like at least 151 those those are
the people that they know of it's
impossible to know how a mess yes going
to the border is like it's easier than
TSA dud they tag your bags they get you
water and they give you a spot to sleep
they don't even check see gun in your
bag no there's so much news happening
right now it's like we've just told a a
history lesson in 10 minutes it's just
crazy I know and I with the Biden thing
I typically agree with you when you say
like having a normaly bias or positivity
bias but I think we're Beyond normaly
right now oh Trump since Trump for sure
and and Biden going there it's like to
me he's a puppet and now I just see the
The Establishment using him as a human
shield to start whatever they want to
start so why would he go unannounced to
Ukraine do you remember he was
unannounced it was a year later and it a
year after the conflict again and so he
goes unannounced to Ukraine but he's
announcing that he's going to Israel why
would you do that it's so you could say
maybe it's to make him appear like a
strong figure cuz he's hasn't been at
all but he's not everybody knows that
right so the argument the argument
people have brought up is that a wartime
president has never lost and I'm like
yeah that ain't Joe Biden though a
wartime president even George W bush
conveys some kind of strength and people
fear a dramatic change but if Joe
Biden's as as frail and pathetic as he
is people are going to beg for change
they're going to be like we need a
leader now please that the joke's over
we're sorry we this guy just gets
anybody else but I mean look there if
we've got 19,000 Personnel already in in
in the waters outside of Israel if if
they are reporting if they're reporting
they intend or or are preparing to go on
the ground then they're they're 10 steps
ahead of where we're what we're already
hearing about yeah I think that's
correct yeah when when they're telling
the troops to get ready for deployment
that that's what they're saying publicly
behind the scenes they've already moved
everything logistically the money's been
circulating the resources Food Supplies
everything's already on the move if
these troops are going to be ready they
need resources before they arrive which
means like it's it's prepped and ready
to go yeah and I don't know you know
nobody knows I guess right now except
for the people and the policy makers
making the decisions what the thought
process is behind this is this to try to
secure some type of humanitarian
corridors through the southern border
there with Egypt is this you know
because at first they talked about the
idea of SEAL Team Six and Delta going in
to help secure uh us hostages which
there are Americans held hostage
currently is what they seem to think and
there's already what is it over
Americans that have died over there in
Israel um
so I I don't know um I don't know what
what you know I guess it's a projection
of strength and they doing it in a
manner to try to deescalate the
situation but it could perhaps do the
opposite I think it I think with 19,000
Personnel in the area that's not
deescalation you send in a single
Diplomat when you want to have a
conversation you call him on the phone
you want to deescalate and show you're
serious you send in a handful of us you
know uh diplomatic Personnel sending in
the war machine is a threat I suppose
the argument is Wag the Wag the big
stick and maybe they'll back down but
Hamas is not a group of people who think
oh no they have better weapons than us
they're staring down the barrel of
Israel Israeli air strikes for a very
long time they don't care they're
ideologically driven and willing to die
for their for their cause so sending the
military there is a provocation let's
get a little conspiratorial and and the
fear is they're prepped for war warships
ready to go we I don't I don't think any
of these people want deescalation
they're warhawks and warmongers they've
been advocating for us involvement Joe
Biden declares beforehand he's going
then everyone in the United States knows
where he's going knows where he is and
he's leaving now and it's announced and
what happens as tensions are escalating
in the region rocket fire today over and
over again into Israel reaching Tel Aviv
Hezbollah strikes on civilian uh
civilian a civilian region civilian
territory or whatever you want to call
it and on
civilians if something happens to Joe
Biden and maybe they're maybe you can
think about in a bunch of different
conspiratorial ways they want him to be
in danger they want risk they want
injury they want him targeted they want
a cause for war it seems like a
sacrifice well every conflict that has
happened there that the United States
has supported Israel which just to be
clear I'm a huge supporter of Israel and
we should be helping the Israelis and we
should be helping the Jewish people but
we've never shown up with two strike
carrier groups mhm to my knowledge that
I remember of I think this puts them I
think this puts Israel at risk it's one
thing when you have the ongoing conflict
between Israel Gaza Palestine Etc we've
seen it going on and on with the uh with
the Gaza war in
2014 it was the Israeli operation
protective Edge we had a great concern I
remember being in The Newsroom that this
could escalate to the point where Iran
declare some kind of involvement or
provide supplies forcing the US to to
respond in kind but that did not happen
it was 51 days things chilled out for
what reason now are they like let's
deploy two two two aircraft carriers and
the president into the region yes SE
we've seen an awful lot too on the other
side like we've seen Putin meeting with
Iran we've seen that Iran has been
meeting with Hamas and Hezbollah like
that's all been documented by The Wall
Street Journal we've seen all of these
reports coming out so I think it's fair
to say that Hamas is ready for something
large scale and longterm they've been
planning this attack for a good couple
of years at this point they've been
planning it basically since Biden got
into office we've seen that the
documentation has come out you know um
and there's no doubt that when Hamas
struck Israel last week there's no doubt
that they were not aware of what the
retaliation would be they knew it would
be fierce they knew that they were going
into war that they were creating war and
they knew that um Israel would have a
disproportionately you know violent
attack that would be incredibly
horrifying for the civilians of Gaza
Hamas knew that of course they knew that
so everything that they are doing either
it's part of their intentional plan or
they're fine with it and they are using
like the the tragedy of their civilians
to generate sympathy exactly and I think
to your point what they want to do is
draw the Israelis in I mean there's
nothing more difficult than Urban
Warfare right right there's nothing more
difficult than that and you will lose
lives and there will be civilian
casualties there's things that are going
to happen in urban Warfare that could um
theoretically and we've seen all the
fake news that's out there about what's
happening uh in this conflict that's
trying to paint the Israelis in a bad
light that could be used uh to Garner
more sympathy um around the world for
the Palestinian cause uh so yeah I mean
I think you're exactly right they're
more than willing to use their own
population as fodder and human Shields
and everything else to be able to
further their cause thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 800m and become a member over
at
timcast.net we'll see you all next
time